et valérie benaïm je crois qu'ils
avaient pensé à vous pour animer la star
ac à un moment où effectivement il
pensait et puis vous savez dans
télévision qu'on appelle des études et
ils font des études auprès d'un panel on
demande à ce que vous préférez un homme
ou une femme est ce qui ressort des
études c'était plutôt on préfère un
homme pour aminé parce qu'on croyait pas
à les tenir a contraint comme ça et donc
ils ont brûlé enlever les des femmes de
la liste et ils ont gardé les hommes et
une élection valérie vous auriez été
magnifique c'est ainsi et moi je les
paie pas et moi vous fait quoi et ben on
va relancer nous lancera tajine academy
à la rentrée les femmes chin
enfin un tajine et en même temps on
chante with mr ouai moi j'ai c'est vrai
que moi j'aimais bien l'époque la star
ac mais il ya les gens qui réclamaient
que la saison youtube ya une attente
bah oui on attend des conflits devraient
confiner le voilà qui nous dit que ça
arrive oui oui merci vous avez juste
avec sur la star se sont sur la star ac
comme sur le loft en fait personne ne
voulait me voulait a présenté le
programme moi je l'eus programme là sur
m6 parce que tout le monde avait refusé
va pas se mentir c'est donc tout le
monde a refusé que la vie a refusé et
nikos était un peu comment à l'époque il
était sûr petite chaîne i ts chroniqueur
je crois c'est sûr mais ils ont d'abord
effectivement une noria et il a il a
pris le job et c'est vrai qu'au début le
pauvre il a beaucoup souffert parce
qu'ils étaient malmenés dans par les
producteurs parce qu'effectivement
n'était pas idée comme tout le monde
j'ai commencé il y avait eu 1 1
un fauteuil qui était balancé dans la
baie vitrée cap était dans le garage est
tellement et décideurs étaient énervés
sur ce qu'il faisait alors que
franchement ce dépliant de mal après